y
[Música]
la unión europea prohibió todos los
vuelos desde el sur de áfrica por la
nueva variante del cob y 19 a la que la
oms se designó como omicron la
restricción aplicará para sudáfrica y
otras seis naciones estas mismas medidas
fueron tomadas por otra decena de
gobiernos
tensión diplomática entre el reino unido
y francia- el elíseo canceló un
encuentro con una alta representante del
gobierno británico para discutir la
crisis migratoria esto tras la muerte de
27 personas que intentaron cruzar el
canal de la mancha de manuel mallo de
exigió seriedad al primer británico
bobby jones
mi presidente de belarús alexander
lukashenko culpa a la unión europea de
la crisis migratoria desde un centro de
acogida le dijo a los migrantes que no
los detendría si quieren pasar a uno de
los países del bloque vitoria respondió
que podría cerrar su frontera
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y los
acompañaré en este recorrido
ante la aparición de una nueva variante
de kobe 19 en sudáfrica decenas de
países suspendieron los vuelos hacia esa
nación la unión europea acordó prohibir
los vuelos desde sudáfrica y también
desde 6 países cercanos como botsuana
mozambique zimbabwe reino unido- impuso
la misma restricción y en américa
latina' guatemala fue el primer país en
prohibir los vuelos desde el sur
africano a pesar de esto la oms e hizo
un llamado a la calma diciendo que se
tardarán semanas en entender el
verdadero impacto sudáfrica calificó las
medidas como draconianas y criticó que
las toma en territorios donde hay nuevas
olas de la pandemia en otras noticias
más reciente la o ms ya designó la nueva
variante como omicron a propósito de
esto nuestra corresponsal en bruselas
esther herrera nos contó previamente al
respecto
los países de la unión europea han
decidido suspender los vuelos de todos
los países provenientes del sur de
áfrica ante el temor de esta nueva
variante que se ha encontrado en
sudáfrica y que podría ser mucho más
contagiosa la medida se tomará lo antes
posible y tendrá una duración de máximo
14 días de momento pero aún así algunos
países europeos ya habían decidido
suspender sus vuelos como bélgica o
italia o también a francia ante el temor
de esta nueva variante pero éste ha
decidido coordinar a nivel europeo para
evitar el caos entre los vuelos aún así
todos los residentes europeos que se
encuentran en estos países podrán volver
pero siempre y cuando estén sujetos a
estrictas cuarentenas aún se desconoce
exactamente cuál es el alcance de esta
variante si realmente es mucho más
contagiosa y si escapa a la inmunidad de
las vacunas algo que aún se está
estudiando lo que sí se sabe es que ya
hay al menos un caso en detectado en
europa y se trata de una mujer residente
en bélgica no vacunada que viajó a
egipto con escala a turquía y que tuvo
síntomas 11 días después de su viaje en
cualquier caso aún se desconoce
realmente si hasta qué punto la
suspensión de vuelos es realmente
efectiva porque hasta ahora cuando se
han suspendido vuelos no han surtido
demasiado efecto por ejemplo ya se hizo
con la aparición de la variante alfa un
proveniente de reino unido y la delta
proveniente de la india y finalmente a
estas dos variantes se han convertido en
las principales en la unión europea y en
las islas de martinica y guadalupe las
autoridades detuvieron al menos a diez
personas tras las manifestaciones en
contra de las medidas para frenar el
commit 19 que terminaron en
enfrentamientos con la policía el
malestar es por la obligatoriedad de las
vacunas para el personal sanitario la
población compara esta medida con un
retroceso a la época de la esclavitud
por no poder decidir por sí mismos ante
los saqueos francia anunció que pospone
esa imposición para los territorios de
ultramar y es que durante esta semana la
región caribeña ha vivido disturbios que
dejaron al menos a una en estado grave
se tensionan las relaciones entre el
reino unido y francia- por la situación
migratoria en el canal de la mancha el
gobierno de manuel retiró la invitación
a londres para reunirse en el puerto
francés de cullen e intentar frenar la
migración el descontento es porque el
´premier´ boris johnson publicó una
carta sobre qué medidas deberían tomar
ambos países esto es sin discutirlo
antes con francia por otra parte también
en cale alrededor de 200 personas le
rindieron un homenaje a los 27 migrantes
que se ahogaron intentando cruzar el
canal veamos más en el siguiente reporte
una reunión para recordar a los muertos
en kale se celebraron vigilias después
de que al menos 27 emigrantes se
ahogaran en el canal de la mancha tras
el incidente boris johnson escribió a su
homólogo francés exponiendo su plan de
acción y sugiriendo que los migrantes
que lleguen con éxito a reino unido sean
devueltos a francia si se devolviera
rápidamente a los que llegan a este país
se reduciría significativamente el
incentivo para que la gente ponga su
vida en manos de los traficantes este
sería el mayor paso que podríamos dar
juntos para reducir la atracción hacia
el norte de francia y romper el modelo
de negocio de las bandas criminales las
otras propuestas del plan del primer
ministro británico son considerar a la
posibilidad de realizar patrullas
conjuntas en barco incrementar el uso de
la tecnología incluyendo sensores y
radares patrullas recíprocamente por
aire y reforzar el intercambio de
inteligencia pero las relaciones
franco-británica si están en un punto
difícil tras cinco años de negociaciones
sobre el presi y el reciente
enfrentamiento por los derechos de pesca
parte el presidente de francia está
molesto por el manejo de la situación
del ejecutivo británico
de
contención para serios pues sorprende
que no se hagan las cosas con seriedad
como líderes no nos comunicamos sobre
estos temas a través de tweets o cartas
publicadas no somos chivatos los
ministros trabajan con seriedad para
resolver un asunto serio con gente seria
de serbios no arreglan cuestión salió
desde rendición salió el ministro
francés de interior del daymán canceló
el viernes las conversaciones con su
homóloga británica pretty patel como
protesta en contra de una carta pública
sobre la crisis de los migrantes de
boris johnson otro foco de tensiones
entre parís y londres sigue siendo la
disputa por los derechos de pesca en
aguas británicas tras los acuerdos del
break city los pescadores franceses
bloquearon los principales puertos del
canal de la mancha para impedir que las
embarcaciones británicas puedan atracar
en francia ellos exigen que les den las
licencias de pesca que necesitan veamos
más en el siguiente informe
el humo de las bengalas tiñe el puerto
de sant malo este viernes de buena
mañana una decena de embarcaciones
francesas echó el ancla para evitar que
los ferrys británicos se acerquen al
muelle durante una hora de bloqueo solo
llega un barco de carga proveniente de
hershey un ambiente amigable y para dar
la bienvenida a la nave británica las
banderas bretona y francesa en sal malo
ya levantaron el bloqueo pero los
pescadores de caleta marón el relevo
para que los barcos ingleses no puedan
acercarse hasta el puerto
es más que nada una acción simbólica
para que el gobierno británico reaccione
si no hay mejoras mostraremos los
dientes
los pescadores franceses reclaman más
firmeza por parte del elíseo en las
negociaciones de las licencias de pesca
con downing street
más de 150 marineros todavía no han
recibido los permisos para pescar en
aguas británicas como emanuel posee que
se felicita por esta movilización casi
nunca antes habíamos visto esto todos
los puertos están movilizados esto basta
bretaña es que nos afecta a todos
acciones contundentes para presionar en
las negociaciones a primera hora de la
tarde los pescadores bloquearon los
ferrys que salen desde west ham también
cerraron las inmediaciones del túnel que
cruza el canal de la mancha por donde
transita el 25% del flujo comercial
entre reino unido y europa el presidente
francés emmanuel mayo se reunió con el
papá francisco en roma' el portal
oficial de noticias del vaticano afirma
que ambos hablaron del clima y de medio
oriente sin embargo aún no se ha
revelado si se refirieron al reporte más
reciente publicado en francia el llamado
informe sobe denuncia que en la iglesia
católica francesa hubo entre 2000 y 3000
hasta que abusaron sexualmente de más de
330.000 menores de edad
el presidente de belarús alexander
lukashenko acusó a la unión europea de
provocar la crisis migratoria en la
frontera con polonia esto por no recibir
a los extranjeros el mandatario se
pronunció desde uno de los centros de
acogida y desde allí le dijo a los
migrantes que no los d tendrían si
quieren pasar hacia el bloque de los 27
por su parte bruselas ha acusado a minsk
de llevar a los migrantes hasta la
frontera y de utilizarlos como arma
política álvaro cordero nos explica
la crisis migratoria en belarús continúa
y su presidente alexander lukashenko
parece estar convencido de que aumentará
si no se encuentra una pronta solución
el mandatario acusó de la situación a la
unión europea y afirmó en una visita a
un centro de migrantes que no los
repartirá y que será difícil contenerlos
en la frontera
y no oprimir 'hemos a esta gente no lo
haremos y si ellos quieren que los
atrape mos en la frontera y los
detengamos tampoco lo haremos ellos no
quieren resolver este problema
no les repatriaremos les pediremos a los
que puedan que se vayan como pueden ver
estoy cumpliendo con mi deber
este mensaje busca poner presión sobre
bruselas que durante semanas lleva
conteniendo a miles de personas
provenientes de medio oriente y áfrica
estos migrantes han tenido que soportar
situaciones límite de frío y hambre las
filas en busca de alimentos se
multiplican al igual que la
desesperación por la incertidumbre algo
que ha hecho que muchos hayan decidido
volver a sus hogares en vuelos de
repatriación
amorosa tú hasta donde enferman a tu
innova habían regresado más 170 personas
y estamos muy agradecidos por llegar a
casa porque la humanidad y la justicia
que la gente dice sobre europa está
lejos de la realidad no es cierto en
absoluto nos han golpeado brutalmente le
estás dao vélez dan la cuestión
migratoria ha acentuado las tensiones
entre la unión europea y belarús ya que
desde el bloque comunitario afirman que
estas personas fueron atraídos por minsk
para desestabilizar a bruselas
rusia aumenta su presencia militar en la
frontera con ucrania así lo dijo el
secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg quien también afirmó que el
kremlin tiene tanques de combate y
tropas preparadas y también dijo que el
uso de fuerzas tendrá un costo por parte
del presidente de ucrania boludo 1000
selenski acosó acusó a moscú de planear
un golpe de estado y dijo que su país
está totalmente listo para una escalada
militar el portavoz del kremlin dmitri
peskov rechazó estas acusaciones
escuchemos lo que dijo el mandatario
ucraniano
yo diría que estamos en guerra con rusia
desde hace 8 años y hace una escalada
más amplia o más baja o una escalada con
rusia o con militantes apoyados por la
federación rusa
creo que esa posibilidad siempre existe
pero también creo que hay una campaña de
intimidación desde diferentes
plataformas de medios hay una gran
campaña de intimidación sobre si la
guerra comenzará mañana o está en camino
lo que debemos saber es que tenemos el
control total de nuestras fronteras y
estamos completamente preparados para
cualquier escalada
hablemos ahora de áfrica porque en
ciudad no todos están tranquilos los
cristianos habían tenido cierto respiro
desde la caída del dictador omar al
bashir en 2019 pero ahora con el
ejército armando el consejo de
transición del país ellos temen que las
cosas vuelvan a ser como antes veamos
más en este reportaje especial de france
el distrito de pizza en los alrededores
de jartúm es una de las partes más
pobres de la capital sudanesa es también
el hogar de una importante comunidad
cristiana igual que muchos otros en
sudán están preocupados por los
disturbios en el país
es terrible para nosotros como sudaneses
ver que nuestra sangre se vierta tan
fácilmente porque la gente muere por
estar pidiendo paz y una vida mejor es
una vergüenza que estemos temerosos de
perder lo ganado en los últimos tiempos
el sentimiento de paz y libertad que
habíamos comenzado a sentir hoy tenemos
nueve de no encontrar la paz y del
sombrío y certero futuro que afronta
sudando
cerca del lugar otra iglesia comparte la
misma ansiedad
[Aplausos]
bajo el régimen de omar al bashir los
cristianos fueron discriminados y sus
iglesias fueron destruidas cani scarlett
fokina busquets el etf o con la iglesia
queda un poco más abajo fue destruida
pensábamos aquí bajo el sol durante
meses las autoridades el antiguo régimen
lo destruyó no pudimos luchar por ellos
la gente en el poder hace lo que quiere
tenemos miedo de que los militares
restauran el viejo régimen
durante la revolución de 2019 mejoró
sustancialmente la vida de los
cristianos aunque no alcanzaron la
igualdad
esta mujer continúa dando la batalla
para preservar las pocas conquistas que
se ganaron serca con lo que me movilizó
como todos los sudaneses queremos un
estado civil y democrático en donde todo
el mundo tenga sus derechos sin importar
su religión que todo el mundo tenga
acceso a los servicios básicos
los cristianos de ciudadan esperan poder
continuar practicando su fe en libertad
como cualquier creyente de otra fe
esperan poder dar un futuro mejor a sus
hijos
y terminamos con una noticia de brasil
porque el ex presidente de los olímpicos
de río 2016 carlos arthur nuzman fue
sentenciado a 30 años y 11 meses de
cárcel él fue hallado culpable de
comprar votos con más de 2 millones de
dólares para que esta ciudad brasileña
fuera la sede de las justas olímpicas
por encima de chicago tokio y madrid el
ejecutivo que estuvo al frente del
comité olímpico brasileño durante más de
dos décadas también fue declarado
culpable de lavado de activos evasión
fiscal corrupción y organización
delictiva
sin embargo nuzman seguirá libre pues su
defensa apeló la sentencia
y hasta aquí las noticias de france 24
ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]